we ran into a tragedy however when I was
four my one-year-old sister died
suddenly from croup form of pneumonia I
guess and she was my mother's attempt to
be born again you might say through her
daughter because these Greek wives live
very tough lives giving how their
husbands were working and when she lost
her beloved daughter she went into very
deep mourning and I as a child who
normally thinks that we I think we think
of ourselves as the center of the solar
system everything revolves around us
were responsible for everything I guess
I wondered why as my mother with droolin
to the deepest deepest depression
psychologically what I did to cause her
to abandon me added to my complexities I
guess you'd say I formed a pattern of
having to achieve and having to be
perfect so I could somehow regain her
her affection and her attention and
that's had some good points and it's had
some bad points because trying to
achieve perfection can be a productive
it can also be a very destructive
process after a while so she had quite
an impact on